after almost 40 years in hollywood jim k  recently announced his retirement from  the industry by saying i have enough  i've done enough  i am enough but how did he become one of  the best comedians of all time  after performing for rodney dangerfield  in 1982 jim carrey moved from toronto to  la to pursue his dream and live in a  closet soon after he became a regular at  the comedy store and even debuted on the  johnny carson show  after getting rejected by snl in 1986  jim carrey scrapped his silly  impressions and became more  observational on stage in 1990 jim  carrey became a cast member on in living  color and the rest is comedy history  soon after he starred in movies like ace  ventura pet detective dumb and dumber  liar liar the truman show and so many  more solidifying him as a bonafide movie  star what do you think will we ever see  jim carrey on stage again let us know in  the comments below